California was for many years the Golden
State Greg Gutfeld and I are both from
there now human waste and drug needles
are piling up in the streets in regular
middle class people are fleeing faster
than they can rent rider trucks it's not
a model to imitate unless you are the
mayor of New York Bill de Blasio he's
looking to open new needle exchange
sites in New York because the city isn't
dirty enough frequent TCT guests
Chadwick more recently tweeted this
quote Street feces in New York City is
already skyrocketing we might as well go
full San Francisco Wow how's that for
depressing Greg Gutfeld host the Greg
Gutfeld show Saturdays at 10 p.m. and of
course every day co-host the 5:00 here
on Fox he joins us great to see you yeah
Street feces was the name of my band by
the way punk polka you know it's
interesting this is how progressive
thinks New York looks at Los Angeles and
thinks hold my herbal tea I can do worse
and so they said they're like de Plaza
was already chosen not to arrest people
over public urination so now they're
technically are the Golden State if
that's disgusting but also amusing and
deeply true yeah but also so predictable
so de Blasio takes over he gets like 15%
of the voter rights thing nobody votes
nobody votes and you look at him and you
think gosh I hope he's not gonna do what
liberals did to the city in the 70s and
in six years he already has and the
reason is is what let's say San
Francisco in Los Angeles and New York
have in common are rich guilty liberals
and and if you have a lot of rich guilty
liberals they will allow for any kind of
bad decisions stupid decisions any kind
of socialist ideas because they can
afford it the other people can't but
they can that's why you have this
incredible wealth inequality in
California you have the Pelosi estates
and then you have the tent cities you
know underneath it and it would I love
about LA is Hollywood creates these
dystopian fantasies like The Handmaid's
Tale and how evil this is they don't
have to they all have to do is look out
the window look out the window it is
exactly right look up the backside of
the Hollywood Hills into the valley by
the way I just noticed you have a gum
that's not mine that's Lou Dobbs that's
new I could just say yes it is I am me
bang I am eBay that's my pocket loo I've
got you and I would admit it I have your
I can put this anywhere and implicate
him in a crime call Mark Fuhrman we now
go to the friends talked to her friends
here at Fox Greg Gutfeld yeah coming up
Greg I've read every one of your books
over many years including your
unpublished post modern novels which
we're weird but I definitely enjoyed
them yeah this is my favorite one really
but yes because it's nonstop yes
brilliant thank you are you just lying
to me right now actually
Tucker Tucker you're right this could be
the greatest book ever I've learned it I
don't think you know what I don't think
it's just the greatest book ever written
it might be the greatest book that will
ever be written so just stop don't even
write any more people put your put your
pens down it ends here these are my
monologues from the five is the end of
literature this is the end of literature
but not just my monologues I add
commentary I to add commentary so what
I'm doing is I'm the first person to rip
apart his own book so where I'm wrong on
my monologues I end up writing why I was
wrong I also update everything so it's
actually two books in one it's like
retsyn doing a retsyn it's like Reese's
P this is a Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
you've got peanut butter and you got
chocolate are you charging double for it
no no I'm not that type of a person I'm
a giver Tucker Wow and you a quote
nipsey Russell in here I dip tea Russell
was an amazing poet from he was often on
Match Game 72 to 75 an amazing mind I
love rhyming writings fun so if you were
to sum up this book in one sentence or
if you were to extract from it its
essence if you were to put it in a
garlic press and squeeze hard what would
come out it's a book about how to
persuade people and how to and how to be
willing to be wrong this is a book in
which I look at my own writing and I see
where I persuaded and where I failed and
I just think it's something that can
entertain you and it's you know it it's
a great gift for Father's Day what's
your biggest fail that was a month ago
this is a joke I don't even know that
and I'm a father yes yes it's a terrible
one yeah apparently an awful father if
you don't know father this is a great
stocking stuffer no again wrong you know
what this is this is for M from you go
right to Amazon no independent
booksellers are better this is a perfect
Labor Day gift it's an amazing Labor Day
it's or if you're in labor yeah exactly
if you're pregnant and
need something to read and it's a long
labor it's an easy thing to carry so
keep your mind off it does you know you
need that the Gutfeld monologues greg
gutfeld great to see you Greg that's a
pleasure Tucker thank come by more often
I enjoy your show you're the best part
of New York big fan